philippe torreton
une torreton bonsoir bonsoir d'être un
grand comédien mais aussi le dernier
étendard d'une certaine idée de la
justice sociale et de la solidarité
nationale vous quand vous parlez de
jaurès vous ne pensez pas à la station
de métro 1 c'est vrai vous ne parlerez
de votre nouveau livre cher françois
lettre ouverte à toi
après deux beaux succès l'an dernier sur
sade avec tir le bergerac et en
librairie avec mémé on retrouve
l'artiste engagé avec un livre intitulé
cher françois lettre ouverte à toi
président publié chez flammarion le
livre fait le livre d'un homme de gauche
qui est déçue par la gauche oui il est
né le 13 octobre
1965 cas à rouen père pompiste mère
institutrice et militante syndicale vous
grandissez dans une cité populaire au
grand-quevilly rue neil amstrong
et puis à votre grand-mère dont vous
parlez dans votre bouquin fabuleuse elle
ne traversait pas un herbage sans
regarder s'il y avait du pissenlit
accueillir les gens qui a arraché mais
c'est vraiment ça c'est des dernières
personnes qui essayait de voir dans la
nature s'il ya quelque chose là c'est
quelque chose a enlevé qui ont de
retenir un chemin pour entretenir et
jusqu'au bout de sa vie elle a planté
des arbres des armes qu'elle ne verrait
jamais grandir elle le savait mais le
plan des des pommiers alors comme vous
êtes très timide en fait votre mère vous
inscrire un stage de théâtre chez
monsieur désir 1 et ensuite vous
rejoignez une troupe amateur qui
s'appelle de l'astragale là vous vous
sentez pousser des ailes vous sortez de
votre enfermement 10 ans et vous
réussissez du premier coup le concours
d'entrée au conservatoire de paris etc
ensuite la comédie française
oblige mais tous les grands rôles du
répertoire suite ya un problème bien sûr
tout comme vous faites capitaine conan
et cta dernier ça commence à créer des
problèmes
avec la comédie française vous partez en
claquant la porte lorsqu'on peut dire
quand même philippe torreton c'est que
vous avez échappé à votre
déterminisme social mais vous n'avez pas
renier votre classe sociale absolument
pas non non non et ça je le dois à mes
parents je dois ma mémé mais je dois
aussi à toute cette famille de gens qui
ont travaillé jeunes pour des salaires
pas très élevé voilà c'est dur les plans
les plans sociaux les conversations du
dimanche qui tournait autour de ça est
ce que l'usv a fermé ou pas ça vous fait
quoi de voir que pas très classe sociale
du régime elle va t elle faire
aujourd'hui ça me fait un peu mal tu as
bien raison de poser la question ça me
fait un peu la contrebande n'est pas
content du tout je ne sais pas qui est
derrière mais personnel c'est ça qui est
génial et donc oui ça fait mal enfin
c'est un ya un signe de colère de
désarroi et qui qui va vers ce vote là
et bon ben voilà c'est à nous deux je
dirais non pas de combattre le front
national le front national ne se combat
pas comme je le dis en exergue de mon
bouquin en citant eric cantona je ne me
bats pas contre une équipe en
particulier je me bats contre l'idée de
perdre on va en parler vous en doutez
bien avec nicolas bay ici présent c'est
pas facile d'être un acteur de bouche
parce que ça vous oblige à bien payer
vos impôts évidemment a déclaré votre
femme de ménage a roulé en peugeot ou en
mono et à éviter les vacances aux
seychelles non pas du tout non ça oblige
pas du tout à tous à hamar le mans ben
voilà ça me pousse à écrire ça me pousse
à dire des choses donc ya pas de je me
conforme pas à quelque chose alors vous
êtes de gauche mais malgré votre talent
de comédien qui est très grand vous
n'arrivez pas à jouer le mec content
d'avoir voté hollande a
c'est l'âge où est ce que je les fais en
second tour comme pas mal de gens à
gauche parce qu'on voulait plus de
nicolas sarkozy alors c'est vrai que ce
soit hollande il vaut mieux être
homosexuel que de gauche en fait parce
qu'ils ont eu le mariage pour tous ouais
mais c'était pas c'est pas une belle
victoire alors que c'est une belle
avancée enfin cette histoire de mariage
pour tous si on peut dire c'est un peu
le cache sexe d'une politique économique
de droite donc un obligé de faire des
mesures de gauche au niveau sociétal
vous savez je pense que je pensais un
peu ça aussi mais alors vous avez fait
un livre qui est publié chez flammarion
qui s'appelle cher françois lettre
ouverte à toi président à vous tutoyez
hollande c'est un peu la dernière chose
de gauche qui lui reste en fait c'est un
peu pour ça que le fait oui oui et c'est
la première fois qu'on fait la remarque
dans ce sens là ouais c'est vrai alors
il ya soixante neuf lettres sur un clin
d'oeil hollande casanova
je me suis fait la réflexion qui a pas
longtemps près je me suis arrêté à 69
ouais c'est un bon chiffre ouais gens me
oui qu'est ce qui se passe mon petit
j'en connais toi écrit des lettres et
langues il espère une réponse oui c'est
comme écrire vous père ne
sais pas s'il y aura une réponse à mon
avis ça dépendra de du succès du lit
écoutez le livre est pas mal du tout
géré leur un certain nombre de phrases
pavot dit celui qui voulait réenchanter
le rêve la désenchantée et a travaillé
la gauche quand même c'est pas rien la
position
assez libérale de 2,2 de cette gauche
socialiste aulas ne m'étonne pas je n'ai
pas découverte là en 2012 mes mails et
le discours du bourget c'est ça qui est
embêtant ça vous reste en travers de la
gorge bah oui parce que ça crée de
l'espoir sur la phrase c'est de même que
inverser la courbe du chômage avant fin
2013 ça finit par créer de l'espoir
c'est que même les plus sceptiques ce 10
mai et s'il avait raison et s'il avait
des chiffres qu'on n'a pas et s'ils
avaient des études sur son perron et
finalement nom vous dit tu as tenté un
truc hyper osé faire du réalisme de
droite une nouvelle pensée de gauche
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est ça veut dire
quoi que le réalisme est forcément de
droite on nous fait croire qu'il est un
certain réalisme à court terme quand on
se base sur les chiffres quand on
compare par exemple la situation d'une
famille à l'endettement de la france
quand on dit si la france était une
femme il y aurait les huissiers à la
porte et c'est ça c'est infantilisant
nous dit qu'en fait vous préféreriez que
les gens soient révoltés plutôt
qu'indigne votre révolte vous le voyez
dans les urnes dans la rue les deux les
deux ans généralement les deux faut tout
faire pour qu'elle soit pas dans la rue
parce qu'après c'est quelque chose qui
qui peut échapper qui peut être
incontrôlables mais si ça doit passer
par la rue ça passera par la rue vous
dites à hollande quelque chose de
terrible ça fait combien de temps que tu
n'as pas serrer le poing
si je dis ça c'est que quand on voit
l'état de notre société quand on voit
qu'on a 10 millions de pauvres à peu
près qu'on a cinq millions 3,5 millions
de personnes qui subissent le mal
logement qui a quand même
trois millions de personnes qui ont un
problème d'eau de d'approvisionnement en
eau en france
ça sa fille de la rage normalement et la
rage fait serrer le poing quand il dit
que il est le président des pauvres gens
veut dire d'être prouve le trouble entre
nous un par séduire julie gayet et
reprendre 10 kg qu'est ce qui n'a fait
hollande
non non il a fait des choses hein mais
c'est timide ça manque d'idéal tout ça
et je crois qu'on le paye ce que voulait
dire en gros c'est qu'il ya pas de
couilles
j'irai pas ça mais ça manque de secours
c'est
[Applaudissements]
évidemment évidemment vous énerver
beaucoup de monde quand vous avez publié
votre lettre à depardieu dans libération
vous avez eu un tas de reproches de neuf
luchini arthur gad elmaleh toute façon
en ce qui concerne gad elmaleh vous avez
laissé hsbc genève répondre
j'avais simplement ajouté quand on
grimpe au cocotier vaut mieux avoir le
cul propre
ce
que terry dont jade affaire c'est que
leur argumentation il est quand même
très bizarre c'est dire que quand on est
un grand acteur on a le droit de pas
payer d'impôts en peut-être que c'est ça
c'est en tout cas mais le toit toutes
les affaires tu n'es pas dans cette
classe là de notoriété donc ouais ça
c'est très maurrassien c'est à dire que
les fils de diplomates doivent être
diplomate a envoyé son ouvrier j'avais
découvert un truc que moi je connais par
coeur parce que j'en souffre depuis des
années c'est le racisme social qu'en
france il ya des classes sociales et
quand on vous dit le contraire c'est pas
vrai mais bien s'il ya des classes
sociales et à l'équité sociale et
mariages mixtes socialement voilà sont
donc très rare il faut le savoir c'est
un pays où un peu comme l'inde où il ya
des castes voilà vous vous êtes dans la
caste des un peu inférieur voyez mais
c'est vrai alors voilà en même temps on
vous a dit vous pourrez ouvrir votre
gueule quand vous aurez la filmographie
de 2,2 par dieu alors ça veut dire qu'il
faut que vous fassiez disco
turf et astérix aux jeux olympiques
à vous de voir mon chéri
thomas guénolé bon soit il est
politologue
docteur en sciences politiques et vous
avez notamment publié il ya un an petit
guide du mensonge en politique
schaeffer's excellent bouquin bienvenue
parmi nous merci alors 2017 le fn est il
déjà gagné la présidentielle
alors on commence avec la bataille des
idées le fn est à 30% mais
69% des français pensent qu'il ya trop
d'immigrés en france
50% des français sont favorables à la
peine de mort
66% des français pensent que la justice
n'est pas assez sévère avec les petits
délinquants
73 pensent qu'on ne défend pas assez les
valeurs traditionnelles donc finalement
le fn est à 30 mais quand on regarde les
chiffres et francis c'est le double en
fait non parce que d'abord il ya des
idées que vous avez cités il n'y a pas
que le fn qui les défend l'idée qu'il ya
trop d'immigrés en france s'est aussi
défendue par l'ump aujourd'hui nicolas
sarkozy a fait campagne sur la sortie
potentielle de l'espace schengen on peut
pas être plus clair le fn at il gagné la
bataille des idées je pense qu' un
certain nombre de thèmes qui maintenant
sont considérés comme normaux dans le
débat public notamment le fait de
débattre sur la présence de trop
d'immigrés ou le questionnement sur la
présence de l'islam ce genre de choses
ça 2 c'est devenu normalisée en revanche
je ne pense pas que le front national
soit normalisée pour autant parce qu'il
ya une contradiction insoutenable soit
c'est le parti anti système soit c'est
un parti normal mais ça peut pas être
les deux c'est précisément parce qu'il
est anti système qu'il arrive à récolter
un certain nombre de voix est ce que le
fn a gagné la bataille des idées
philippe torreton non non non je crois
pas le fn se sert d'un désarroi d'une
devrait constat d'échec dans notre
société d'une douleur d'un peuple à qui
on demande des efforts qui voit bien
cette inégalité qui profite aussi de
cette imbécillité ambiante qui est
d'attaquer bille en tête avec des
expressions toutes faites le front
national moi je crois qu'on ne fait
jamais campagne contre quelqu'un on fait
campagne pour des idées et on a
abandonné le terrain des idées on doit
faire confiance en politique et c est
parce que ça me rappelle un film de
science fiction dont j'ai oublié le
titre d'ailleurs il ya une créature
venue de l'espace et plus on lui tirer
dessus plus elles grossissent et elle
profiter et finalement lui envoie les
armes nucléaires qu'elle devient énorme
et elle bouffe tout le monde eh ben je
crois que c'est ça aussi le front
national c'est que plus on vit tireurs
valides se dira s'il a tort metop ahmed
accords de dakar il a tort de
stigmatiser du de la journée commence
bien sûr avec ses expressions à
l'emporte-pièce complètement y compris
même sur l'apartheid social qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut rien dire ok
absatou est ce que le fn a gagné la
bataille des idées je ne pense pas
qu'ils aient gagné la bataille des idées
on parle souvent de vote de rejet de
vote d'adhésion je suis pas sûr que les
gens ils adhèrent c'est juste
qu'aujourd'hui il y en a qui considère
que c'est l'heure la seule solution qui
leur reste et puis le pire c'est quoi
c'est que le front national bénéficie
aujourd'hui des tâches et presse
bénévoles qui sont nos politiques nos
politiques qui ne sont pas à la hauteur
de ce qu'on attendait qu'ils ne nous
nous propose des choses mais n'y a pas
d'action sont incapable de réformer et
un moment quand on se retrouve dans
cette situation les gens ils ont envie
de gueuler et pour gueuler aujourd'hui
ils votent front national
quand ça va pas durer
de vote de rejet veulent je compte les
chiffres que vous avez donné tout à leur
montre qu' un vote d'adhésion sur front
national que nous avons gagné une
bataille des idées une bataille
culturelle et j'ai même plus loin ce
côté philippe torreton tout à l'heure
qui nous disait moi j'ai voté hollande
uniquement par rejet de sarkozy et je
crois que ça traduit profondément la
réalité des votes ump ps et je crois en
revanche qu'aujourd'hui le front
national parce qu'il porte un projet
différent ça vote d'alternative
politique alors on passe aux points 2 le
fn est capable d'être premier au premier
tour on en est à peu près persuadé
aujourd'hui le problème c'est le
deuxième tour parce que le premier aussi
une primaire on fait ump ps pour savoir
qui s'opposera à marine le pen au
deuxième tour alors après au deuxième
tour il ya trois solutions soit c'est
sarkozy soit c'est juppé soit c'est
hollande voilà qui est capable de battre
marine le pen au deuxième tour
n'importe lequel n'importe lequel on
pensait que n'importe qui n'importe qui
le bat marie noble âge est rattachée à
un piqué avec étiquette je ne suis pas
fn battrait marine le pen au second tour
vous êtes bronzés les enjeux vous
explose mais c'est pas que c'est pas qui
c'est les bras pas à mon avis en fait au
premier tour il ya plusieurs strates de
vote qui votent fn est alors par rapport
à la question vote d'adhésion votre
fonction etc il ya plusieurs strates il
ya un vote pardon mais c'est
historiquement il ya un vote de
conviction racistes anti blancs et senna
se terminer mon raisonnement je vous ai
pas intervenus mais tous les électeurs
fn ne sont pas dans ce cas là il faut le
dire un moment donné il ya une deuxième
couche ça ce sont des électeurs qui ont
plus d idées on va dire radicalement de
droite sur les valeurs et les sujets de
société qui trouvent que le rpr enfin
maintenant l'ump ils sont trop mollasson
et qui donc sont passés au fn c'est une
deuxième strate c'est par là même que la
première il ya une troisième strate eux
ils sont non alignés partisans ils en
ont rien à cirer et il vote anti système
il met un bulletin dans l'urne le
bulletin fn pour faire sauter la banque
et il ya une quatrième couche qui est en
train d'apparaître qui est très fine qui
est très fine mais c'est ça tout
l'objectif de la stratégie philippot à
mon avis c'est arrivé à obtenir que des
électeurs de gauche classes populaires
commencent à voter fn parce que sinon
ils peuvent pas dépasser le plaindre
qu'ils ont déjà fait un second tour de
deux choses l'une au second tour soit
marine le pen est contre un candidat de
droite et dans ce cas là la quasi
intégralité de la gauche fait front
commun en allant voter à droite même si
c'est sarkozy
mais les gens de gauche ont voté pour
sarkozy mais aux éditions pas chirac en
2002 si jamais ça se produit je donne
rendez vous à tous ceux qui font les
malins en disant mais attendez sarkozy
contre le pen je voterai pas sarkozy
c'est au pied du mur qu'on voit le maçon
et moi je vous dis que la quasi
intégralité des électeurs de gauche en
se bouchant le nez tout ce que vous
voulez ils voteront quand même pour
sarkozy contre le pen j'en entends qui
nie on les reverra très bien et dans
l'autre sens dans l'autre sens il ya la
moitié des électeurs de droite et la
totalité des électeurs centristes qui ne
veulent pas du fn et qui donc votre
épaule candidat donald tusk s'est plié
au gaz est pas allé par présidente non
moi je pense qu'on peut gagner au
deuxième tour on l'a déjà montré dans
différentes élections au scrutin
majoritaire si on passe la barre des 30%
à peu près au premier tour on peut
gagner au deuxième tour je pense que les
français aujourd'hui progressivement ça
en train de se faire à l'idée et
certains avec enthousiasme que le front
national gagne en 2017 la force du front
national aujourd'hui c'est de rassembler
des français venant d'horizons assez
divers sociologiquement politiquement
des gens de droite des gens de gauche et
qui aujourd'hui sont d'accord sur un
point c'est la nation c'est-à-dire
l'idée que la nation n'est pas un
concept dépassé et obsolète que ça reste
le meilleur moyen de protéger notre
économie que ça reste le meilleur moyen
de protéger notre identité notre
sécurité nos libertés fondamentales et
vous avez de l'autre côté une classe
politique ump ps et leurs alliés qui
défendent une autre vision et mais qu'il
devrait assumer les verts on lui dit
assume c'est la logique mondialiste
ultralibéral l'europe n'étant en fait
qu'une espèce de phase intermédiaire
dans cette logique mondialiste le très
libéral va en parler alors justement
aujourd'hui quand même ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que ce plan sociétal les
idées du fn en tous les cas on bien
pénétré la société française le problème
reste le programme économique du fn qui
est absolument incroyable et je pense
que si marine le pen veut avoir une
chance d'accéder au pouvoir pour qu'elle
mette de l'eau dans son vin sur le plan
économique parce que on est parti d'un
jean marie le pen qui était libéral
satie à rien reaganien etc le programme
avait été écrit par gérard longuet donc
c'est assez normal et aujourd'hui le
front national de marine le pen est
carrément socialistes et d'abord cette
idée de sortir du de l'eurobond et on
revient au froid etc mais le fn
aujourd'hui pense assez l'idéologie
officielle du fn la concurrence libre
promeut la loi de la jungle donc ce que
nous propose le fn c'est une
planification avec des plans
quinquennaux avec des bancs bastille
avec des banques partiellement
nationalisées
des services publics repris
intégralement à la charge de l'état ça
coûtera moins cher les 50 plus grandes
entreprises françaises non nationalisés
devront affecter 15% de leurs bénéfices
en réserve de réindustrialisation
l'impôt sur les sociétés va passer à 50%
augmentation des salaires de 200 euros
la retraite à 60 ans d'abord le front
national dans les années 80 mais une
approche c'est vrai plus libérale bah
oui mon sens au sens des libertés
économiques pourquoi parce que il y
avait encore des frontières on était
avant maastricht avant schengen
aujourd'hui le problème est le suivant
nous n'avons plus de protection en
mettant en place des quotas des droits
de douane ou des contingentements ça
évite le dumping social du dumping
environnemental
le front national aujourd'hui défend à
la fois et ça n'est pas du tout
contradictoire les libertés économiques
la liberté d'entreprendre l'allègement
des charges sur les petites boîtes le
soutien à l'économie réelle en ayant en
évitant de multiplier la nationaliser
conscients de l'imminence tracts il
s'évade même temps et dans le même temps
c'est vrai un état qui intervient dans
le domaine économique quand c'est utile
un état stratège qui peut faire des
investissements qui peut éventuellement
me nationalisée s'il ya une filière qui
en difficulté et surtout qui reprend la
main sur la grande finance parce que
c'est ça l'enjeu philippe torreton est
ce que cet endroit là c'est à dire cette
proposition d'une économie dirigée par
l'état extrêmement colbertiste est-ce
que ça rejoint pas d'extrême gauche
finalement il ya des choses qui
pourraient faire penser que ça rejoint
mais mais mais mais je n'y crois pas
dans ce sens là il ya d'abord parce que
ça repose à mon avis sur un énorme
mensonge originel par rapport à
l'émigration comme d'un poids comme d'un
boulet la france et l'immigration est
une richesse quand j'étais petit mes
copains étaient portugais et certaines
personnes peut-être des gens comme vous
les appelez les portes hausse c'était
mes potes
mcneil et maccarone mulipola peut pas
dire qu'il ait posé de problèmes
d'assimilation donc ça attendez moi mes
ancêtres maternels comme ceux de filippo
d'ailleurs son polonais et figurez-vous
que à la sortie des mines ça se fera
casser la gueule à coup de barres de fer
avec les immigrés polonais pourquoi
parce qu'il volait le 1 il volait le
travail des vrais français et bien sûr
et 2 qui posait un problème
d'intégration culturelle parce que vous
comprenez leur religion poser problème
la france est un pays laïque alors je me
dis comme à chaque vague migratoire
c'est la même histoire est ce que dans
ce prix on a un problème d'immigration
est ce qu'on a un problème de racisme
j'ajouterai en fait il ya deux discours
qu'il faut pas confondre parce qu'il
s'adresse pas au même strate de
l'électorat fn il ya le discours
racistes sur les arabes mais on va dire
les musulmans parce que comme ça on peut
dire que c'est un problème de religion
entre un problème des arabes bon
personne n'est dupe et puis après il ya
le discours sur l'immigration économique
est là c'est pas du tout la même
histoire parce que l'idée que
l'immigration économique pic le boulot
des français il ya même des électeurs de
gauche et des électeurs couches
populaires à gauche qui sont d'accord
avec çà et je vous dire le fond de ma
pensée je pense que la gauche n'arrivera
jamais à se réconcilier avec l'électorat
ouvrier temps qu'elle défendra pas elle
même le fait que les français soient
prioritaires dans l'accès à l'emploi je
vais être parfaitement clair là dessus
tant que la gauche n'enlèvera pas les
eaux hier sur la nécessité d'introduire
des quotas socio-économique
d'immigration le front national pourra
continuer à utiliser l'argument
l'immigration économique et ça c'est un
aspirateur à voie de gauche il faut
qu'il fasse attention il ya une question
quand même pour finir pourquoi la grèce
a series à l'espagne 1 podemos et nous
on a le front national je suis content
que vous me posez cette question parce
que moi ma conviction c'est que
les pays où c'est l'extrême gauche qui
rafle le vote anti système c'est parce
qu'ils ont une expérience historique
beaucoup plus récente des dictatures
d'extrêmement c'est vrai les colonels et
franck rouas sur exactement risque pas
de voter pour eux voilà bah alors moi à
mon avis c'est ça bonne réponse
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un peu
de bleu